everyone remembers how governor abbott
of texas
he rescinded some of these mandates
governor newsom of california
tweeted out that it was unacceptable or
i don't remember what term he is but he
was basically condemning it
nothing happened as a consequence and
everyone pretended it didn't happen so
if you have these big rallies which
they're going to be described as white
supremacist rallies they're going to
describe that way anyway
uh and this is showing people we're not
going to
stand six feet apart from each other and
no one's going to die as a consequence
we're going to be safe and so on and so
forth
that kind of element of defiance is
useful
because people in the middle is
something called the bandwagon effect
people in the middle are who don't
really have a political opinion one way
or another
but basically you know all my life i'm a
new yorker i'm not a sports fan
people like yankees or mets i would say
mets because i like the blue and the
orange better i
literally have no other mechanism for
choosing but if you have no mechanism
for choosing
you're going to go to the people who are
having fun yeah you're going to go the
people who have the energy
so if you have one group that's like be
miserable never go to a concert
the other one's like don't you want to
have like rock and roll and listen to
even elvis
it's like yeah i'm gonna go to where the
people are having fun are and that's a
big threat to their control
i've been saying for a while i mean all
of us have a limited window on social
media i'm thrilled that i think you were
the second guy on local
basically and and you're killing it on
there but it seems to me that because of
exactly what you
just said there that the jig is up
they've been exposed everyone gets it
they can't let us on youtube and twitter
and facebook much longer like it just
can't it's not tenable
but i've always said there's going to
have to be alternative
sources into for people and their
culture has to bifurcate
in order to go forward back in the day
it was abc nbc cbs
now in terms of news there's literally
thousands of sources some of them are
completely wrong and misinformation and
cookie
some of them it's a spectrum some are
you know objective and spot on the money
they are the only way the new york times
can be the new york times
in terms of stature is if it has close
to monopoly on the microphone
and i don't see how like humpty dumpty
once that egg is shattered
how you put it back together again you
were never going to be
again as a country and it's not even in
terms of the news look at like the mash
finale
for kids there was a show called nash
which is about the korean war what was
the number what was the number on the
finale
60 million yeah but even the super bowl
yeah this was something that everyone
air quotes in america is watching
you can't get that together in terms of
the new york times or even cbs abc nbc
and nbc news anymore our country has
become too split up
and that's choice is the basis of
liberalism
that's what liberalism means you have as
many options and you're free to choose
as you wish but this is a big threat
because their entire worldview is based
on their depravity and malfeasance
they're more upset that someone had
their feet up on nancy pelosi's desk
that many people in the elites were
possibly engaging in statutory rape
with jeffrey epstein and abc news knew
about this and didn't inform the
authorities
but the guy had his feet up he was
wearing his shoes he took a picture i
mean
were they still leather they were not as
fancy as your shoes that's for sure
so at what point do you think we've
crossed the rubicon here have we crossed
the valley let's say where we should
just start ignoring them i i struggle
with this all the time
because okay go ahead the battle is one
when the average american regards a
corporate journalist exactly as they
regard a tobacco executive
now whenever i say this some midwit has
to get on twitter and say the tobacco
executive's much better
yeah i said regards and that is the next
step
you have to realize i'm not catholic
you're not catholic
uh i like the pope some of the popes i
like some i don't like
you can hear him out but there's no
reason for me
to believe everything he says or to
trust him to some exceptional degree
so the thing is there's no reason the
same way to believe
cnn fox nbc these are corporate entities
with an agenda and if you're at a point
where coca-cola
is telling their employees to be less
racist it's
given coca-cola's extremely racist
history right they
sort of backed off this thing though
right they didn't they delete some of
the
diversity and inclusion and that's the
point like now they are
trying their shenanigans but people are
on to them and instead of trying to have
this
lively debate it's like we're not having
this conversation this is just a
mechanism for you to further your power
and we're going to have to fight back
because i am not going to bend the knee
to your nonsense any longer
especially because constantly and
explicitly
you're coming for our children do you
think it's possible that they've awoken
a real lion here like a real beast and i
mean that in the best sense that i
i just tweeted this out in the last
couple hours something about like we
need
rallies again like the trump rallies
were so much joy so much positivity
so much true diversity and all of that
stuff and i'm not saying it has to be
trump doing it i personally wouldn't
have a problem if it was trump
but like do we just need like they in
effect they've awoken something that we
must get out there and show them that
we're here that that's the only way and
they locked us in our houses
to make sure we couldn't do it do you
know why while they bowed at protesters
those rallies are a great idea for the
simple reason
that it's a symbol of defiance yeah uh
everyone remembers how governor abbott
of texas
he rescinded some of these mandates
governor newsom of california
tweeted out that it was unacceptable or
i don't remember what term he is but he
was basically condemning it
nothing happened as a consequence and
everyone pretended it didn't happen
so if you have these big rallies which
they're going to be described as white
supremacist rallies they're going to
describe it that way anyway
uh and this is showing people we're not
going to
stand six feet apart from each other and
no one's going to die as a consequence
we're going to be safe and so on and so
forth
that kind of element of defiance is
useful
because people in the middle is
something called the bandwagon effect
people in the middle are who don't
really have a political opinion one way
or another
but basically you know all my life i'm a
new yorker i'm not a sports fan
people like yankees or mets i would say
mets because i like the blue and the
orange better i
literally have no other mechanism for
choosing but if you have no mechanism
for choosing
you're going to go to the people who are
having fun yeah you're going to go the
people who have the energy so if you
have one group that's like be miserable
never go to a concert
the other one's like don't you want to
have like rock and roll and listen to
even elvis
it's like yeah i'm gonna go to where the
people are having fun are and that's a
big threat to their control so in many
ways this is what you would have wanted
to happen a long time ago at some level
right
that the right the new right to use the
title of your book that the new right
would become the place that was creative
and cool and there would be music and
parties and fun and
sex and all of those things that humans
are supposed to do and all the left has
is preening fake morality and hysteria
and lunacy well i don't i i mean i'm
going to be a little bit pedantic i
apologize i wouldn't call it fake
morality
they really have a very strict
puritanical morality
which is fake meaning it's not moral in
a
objective sense no it is moral and
objective sense in the sense that like
it
a morality let's get my yaron brook hat
on okay
uh morality in the iran sense is
basically a code of ethics
or code of values which governs every
aspect of your life
keeping kosher in the jewish ethics is a
good example of acting
ethically every choice you make with
your food is
guided by this ethical code they've and
they've extended that
to literally every aspect of your life
who you sleep with
uh what kind of food you eat it's gotta
you know be ethical local so on and so
forth
how you dress what shows you watch who
you
interview on your own set and
it's it's just amazing to what extent
this is the other thing i point out
if you're talking i talk discussed about
this in my book if you're talking about
video games
sci-fi fantasy comic books places where
people go to escape reality
and escape the earth and have this kind
of sense of adventure
their morality and their world view even
permeates there
there's nowhere on earth space time or
the future where you can go to escape
their edicts
and at a certain point many people are
like i don't
want to live like this i want to judge
my friends
on are they going to be there for me
when i have a tragedy
or not who they voted for or whether
they think trump is hitler as opposed to
maybe they think he's just a buffoon
how much further will they crack down
then right they're not going to just
give up like okay so we start
rallies again we're creating good stuff
we're doing
all the stuff that you would like to see
happen and by the way i do think it's
happening right
oh yes it is happening there's no doubt
about it but they're not just going to
give up they're not just going to walk
away and and even when coke reverses
slightly it's
diversity stuff it's like well what are
you really saying yesterday you were
telling half your employees that they're
racist now you got exposed
so they're not like i remember last year
what did we do with this
i i meant i said the the riots are about
72 hours away from having corporate
sponsorship
and it was like like two hours later
everyone's bending over backwards
to endorse these uh um the civil unrest
playstation i literally turned on my
playstation and it offered me a free
black lives matter
background on there yeah right but it's
amazing to what it's right so everything
has to be permeated
with this very speci and it's not only
like it it'll be one thing if they had
said
we want people to value black lives more
it specifically just has to be this one
slogan
and we're this month we're only caring
about black people
next month we're caring about this group
next month occurring about this group
and if you're a poor white person and
you're resentful
well you had your turn you know go home
and suck it up
uh so i i don't think this is something
that's going to be able to last much
longer
and i have to give credit to people on
the left people like james carville
van jones and some others where they're
like this is something that cannot
long-term sustain itself and britain of
all places i mean
talk about just uh in terms of backward
[ __ ]
they just had their local elections
after having a new leader for labor
which is one of their two main parties
cirquier and he was much more
uh to the center than their previous
leader jeremy corbyn they had their
off-year elections
and they were seeing their biggest
losses since like world war
ii so if you're and you're seeing this
also in germany uh the social democrats
which are
historically the second biggest part in
germany are now polling at like 11 or 12
so in country after country this old
coalition
of the left being the party of the labor
unions the working man
they now have such contempt for the
working man especially in america since
reagan
when you had union workers who were
voting republican
they just threw themselves they got
thrown to the garbage as quickly as
possible
and this is what i think people on the
right don't understand they
don't care about muslim immigrants
mexican people at the border
transgender rights it's whatever group
is of use
at the moment to further their agenda
and once that group is not
behaving or acting in the way that they
like they're just swiftly discarding
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell